now you've got 60-year-olds fighting
20-year-olds when they made them maybe
if you didn't give an eighth place
trophy your kid wouldn't be entitled
jenz is not lazy Jen just knows the game
they don't want to work for UK Kmart for
12 bucks an hour they can just sell some
[__] on eBay or stock they got options
if I had the internet and social media
when I was 15 [__] College I would have
not graduated middle school middle
school there's plenty of gen Z kids that
are working harder than anybody I've
ever seen I've got a bunch of these kids
on my team and are grinders and there's
gen Z kids that are lazy good news I
know unlimited people in their 70s who
are lazy as [__] as if every Boomer
worked their [__] ass off unlimited
Boomers were lazy as [__] they got
[__] options they can go to [__]
Goodwill buy nine things go home make a
Tik Tok video about it put it on eBay
and make paper they got options